[Music]
this is star talk cosmic queries edition
i'm your host neil degrass tyson your
personal astrophysicist and my guest
co-host today is a friend of star talk
the one and only paul mercurio paul hey
neil how are you welcome back to star
talk nice to be back great to see you
again man let me just remind people who
you are like you started out was it an
investment banker or something yeah and
that wasn't funny enough for you so you
became a comedian well i started what
the hell happened there and how much of
a disappointment were you now to your to
your family
then and now
i i can't even say that i was a lawyer i
was saying i'm sorry i got it i mean no
no bo you got it right i was i was doing
m a law and i was like
okay well mergers and acquisitions see
you're still in it you're saying no
sorry
exactly exactly exactly
i was gordon gekko with big lips and uh
and then i decided well i want to really
sort of you know be a little bit more
scummy so i'm going to be an investment
banker and then i
i hadn't saw your um investment bankers
wasn't scummy enough for you
exactly exactly it's like why am i
defending these guys when i could be one
of them be making four times the money
and uh so i'm like let me go jump ship
and i was still doing uh immersion
acquisitions but on the banking side and
the difference is like the bankers sort
of come up through the financial
modeling to
decide the value of the company and then
they get into a price negotiation and
they hand it off to the lawyers and then
we negotiated so you're already in how
that all that worked anyway that's what
it seems like yeah yeah um
so if you got put out of a job because
an m a deal just tweet me you can uh
here's my address if you want to come
and burn my house down it might have
been you it might have been me and then
i thought um how could i disappoint
everybody in my life including my wife i
know i'll go into comedy and
entertainment and start all over again
and then that's what i did no i enjoyed
your story we had lunch recently and you
were telling me that
the part of the birth you know the
origin story of paul mercurio was
selling a couple of handwritten jokes to
jay leno for the tonight show that
that's just i'd love that i'd love it
and now you're you're you did the
warm-up for a stephen colbert
yeah yeah and then and the late show and
the late show i wrote on the daily show
worked on the colbert report and i work
on that this show and then appear on the
on the late show occasionally too okay
so if i'm ever watching stephen colbert
and his audience looks a little
dead it's because you didn't you failed
[Laughter]
because you're supposed to get them all
excited
right no it's because i wasn't there and
some lame-o called in for me
it was a good one yeah uh yeah no it's a
it's this weird sort of thing you can't
do jokes in it because it doesn't work
in that setting you need like an
intimate space and with cocktail tables
kind of space yeah yeah you know yeah
you know and then you know angry
waitresses serving around you that kind
of thing and then uh
just to remind people that his show is
in the ed sullivan theater so it's
actually a theater not just a little
recording space right yeah it's pretty
incredible i mean you've been to the
show and i don't know if you saw it
downstairs but below they have these
huge timbers and an elephant painted on
the wall and it turns out that
they used to have the ringling brothers
circus perform in the theater and they
would bring the elephants in on the 53rd
street entrance and they needed to put
these timbers up to support the stage
because of the elephants so just to be
clear the ringling brothers came to
perform at madison square garden
not only on the end sullivan show
so so this was like pr for the regular
show right yeah that silver show to
watch a free ring circus right
exactly well a couple of the elephants
for divas they wouldn't even go on the
sullivan show they're like i don't need
that and they're just they're just
looking at their hooves like what what
um do i do elephants have hooves no i
don't think so i don't think so they're
like i call them big feet
i was starting to feel stupid when you
corrected me then your answer didn't
make me feel so stupid now
they have those big feet
and uh so yeah i mean so it's a it's a
compact thing like in 10 or 15 minutes
you gotta it's it's a weird to go into a
tv taping for an audience it's strange
because a lot of people haven't been
before so you don't really know and i
think sometimes
they think you have to kind of actually
be quiet and like polite and yeah yeah
yeah because otherwise you interfere
with the filming right right yeah they
think they're
right and the whole vibe is that they
create this wave of energy and we kind
of surf it so um i mean you know you've
been on it they they love you i mean
you've been heckled a couple of times we
cut that out and at it and
i can't believe somebody threw a pie at
you from the balcony i thought that was
highly inappropriate
[Laughter]
it was something like you haven't
returned my email in three years and
then he threw a pie at you
i was like wow this guy's got a lot of
enemies uh no well i like reintroducing
you to our audience so it's great to get
something appreciated so did you come
loaded with questions from our audience
and what's the theme today uh the theme
is sort of a grab bag we uh okay we have
those every now and then yeah yeah yeah
but there does seem to be a little bit
of a through line of sort of uh
you know in terms of the galaxy and sort
of uh okay measurements but let's if i
know the answer i'll
you know
i read through these ahead of time i
don't think you're going to know any of
this no that's i will just end it here
why don't you just have a glass of wine
and i'll take over uh mr big feet and um
all right so we'll get started then yeah
let's do it okay i apologize on this
first name it's a little tricky but i'm
doing my best here it's uh haday uh
wagomans and the question is do we know
where hede comes from
uh we like knowing their origin we do
not know okay i just have the name um by
the way and patreon i think yeah yeah
all these are patreon right so patreon
um they get perks for supporting the
show
and
uh so we love them for that and here and
here we have it so yeah so what do you
have
um if the universe expands at light
speed how does it expand
at light speed and uh by the way i've
listened to all of the episodes of star
talk radio you don't have to kiss ass
you're going to get your answer here
you don't need to
well at least he said it at the end of
the question right rather than at the
beginning
right that's that shows a little more
class yeah exactly
uh so yeah if the universe expands at
light speed how does it expand that
light speed
yeah that's a common um
[Music]
concern people have when they learn of
this
and
because they know fundamentally that
nothing can travel
faster than light so how is it that the
universe could possibly expand faster
than light in fact if you go to the
early universe
right after the big bang
it was expanding way faster than the
speed of light so here's here's where
the rubber hits the road or the
spaceship hits the vacuum or however
that way
however that'll work
so
so einstein's
in 1905
einstein came out with his quote theory
of relativity but that theory of
relativity was in a very restrictive
case
okay and so it came to be known as the
special theory of relativity not because
it was special like you're special no no
it's not that it's because it was a it
was a
limited
invocation of the principles of
relativity so it's a special case really
is how is what it should have been
called really
and it would take him another 10 years
to generalize the principles of
relativity to a much larger
more encompassing
um concept and that which by the way
which by the way proves 10 years
he was lazy let's be honest you think
what that is i could have done it
i could have done it too anyway
so it became the so the special theory
of relativity broadened to become the
general theory of relativity
okay so that's that's what's going on
there and so it turns out in special in
the special theory of relativity it
describes what happens when you move
through
a pre-existing space and time
and if you're trying to move through
pre-existing space and time
there are speed limits
the speed of light
it's not just a good idea
it's just
what happens is it possible to exceed
but you have to finish the line it's not
just a good idea
it's the law
don't you remember this i'm sorry
i missed it
i'm sorry i missed it have you been
living in new york so long you forgot
how to drive and you forgot those rules
about the speed limit exactly exactly
i totally missed it yes all right it's
it's it's not just a good idea it's the
law it's the law you missed it you know
i'm hanging these low low low-heated
fruit
so the universe so what's interesting is
uh
photons packets of energy do move at the
speed of light but anything with mass
cannot ever achieve the speed of light
under the tenets of the special theory
of relativity and what happens is the
circumstances become oddly interesting
right so if you're going to watch me
move faster and faster and faster you
will see
that my time will begin to slow down
you'll compare my clock to yours
if i'm on a spaceship and you're down
here on earth and you watch me fly by my
clock will tick slower than your clock
and not only that you will see the
length of my spaceship shorten in the
direction i'm moving
and you will see that my mass has
increased and i will have no idea any of
that is happening
so even though you see my spaceship
getting shrunk front to back i'm in the
spaceship and i looked behind me i
looked in front of me and it's a normal
spaceship
so
the point that einstein noted this is
part of one tiny piece
of his vast brilliance
is that
while i'm on the spaceship if i try to
measure the length of the spaceship my
ruler shrinks as well
so i'll still measure the same length
even though you're gonna say hey neil
you know you're really shrunken up i
said no i haven't and i take out my
shrunken ruler and i say everything is
mine is it's a is it is it okay so
here's what happens that's a great
question it's a great question so
what um
the reason well
i recall the reason like that like
someone made this a reason it is just
the reality of the universe in which we
live
and it's that
everybody measures the same speed of
light
no matter how fast you're going right so
if you're on the front of a train
let's say a train is going 60 miles an
hour and then you throw a rock
10 miles an hour in front of you
okay you're standing on the train and
the rock is leaving you 10 miles an hour
okay
someone on the ground will see the rock
go 10 miles an hour plus the speed of
the train
okay
so those those the trains are only 60
they'll see the rock going 60 like going
10 and so the rock 10 in front of the
train is actually going 70 miles an hour
it adds for that person okay i was just
thinking it would catch up but it does
it no no it doesn't no no once you throw
it it will fall but if you just throw it
out ahead now watch
if i send a beam of light in front of me
i will measure to have the speed of
light
you on the ground try to measure that
same beam of light even though i beamed
it in front of a train
and you also get the exact same value
for the speed of light
this is freaky right the speed that you
measure for light
is independent of how fast you're moving
so einstein said
how do i make that happen
in the calculations the only way we can
all agree
that the speed of light is the same no
matter who's measuring it is if my
length shrinks as i go by you is if my
mass increases and my time slows down
so that simple observation about the
universe that everybody measures the
same speed of light forces all the rest
of that to be true and that is the
special theory of relativity
okay so now
10 years goes by because he's just such
a lazy bum and then he figures out
how to think about this
with regard to
accelerations so
not just how fast you're going but
suppose
you're accelerating suppose
and what so he
the full answer to this question would
take an hour but i'm going to shorten it
and say
that the expanding universe
is not an object moving within the
pre-existing universe and therefore the
speed of light
plays no role in constraining it
so it can expand at any rate of speed
arbitrarily fast because nothing is
moving
faster than light within the medium
it is the stretching of the medium
itself and that's so and that was it
allowed in the general theory of
relativity which still contra contrains
your speed if you're trying to move
within the space itself
and so if something can expand with no
parameters
is it is it possible to measure to
measure that in any way
what will happen is as the as the univ
if so you'll see a part of the universe
expanding and let's say it hits the
speed of light
well the light it tries to send you will
lose all energy before it reaches you so
it basically disappears and it creates a
horizon for you
and so
yeah yeah so so that's what's
interesting so there's more universe out
there it's just beyond the horizon and
that light will never reach you
because the universe is expanding faster
than the speed of light can come towards
you so
so yeah it's gone forever so you'll
never even see the thing objects
embedded in space moving at the speed of
light or greater
so the short answer to but uh you know
if the universe expands how does it
expand that light speed
it is very complicated it's not sort of
it's this or it's that it just depends
on the medium and the circumstances no
it depends if it's because the
space is expanding not objects moving
within the space at the speed of light
so that's that's that's the fundamental
difference there
okay and there's a really brilliant
reason
how and why einstein came up with this
concept of the general theory of
relativity the equivalence principle and
i i could get into it if we have time
but
we're going to take a break in like a
minute but i just want to say
that the short answer here is
general theory of relativity allows
space to expand at arbitrary speeds and
it is not constrained by the speed of
light whereas we are because we're
embedded in a pre-existing spacetime and
we cannot then go faster than life yeah
i
mean
let me be clear you all are i am not
constrained i'm a whole other being
that is able to morph
i'm i'm the bad guy and terminator there
you go
by the way
by the way the terminator two to get you
you know
yeah okay i hate it when you correct me
and you know i'm just i'm not actually
correcting i'm just enhancing the truth
of what you say
wow you must be fun to get in an
argument with your wife
honey i'm not correcting you i'm
enhancing you well enhance outside
because you're not sleeping in this bed
tonight
so
um
oh so so science fiction authors know
all about this limit of the speed of
light and they don't want to violate
that all right it's like sacrosanct so
what they do is they come up with other
methods that circumvent the speed of
light limit like warp drives and what do
they do they're distorting the fabric of
space and time and traveling and surfing
that or traveling through wormholes and
these are all other ways you can get
from a to b faster than a beam of light
would have
but you're not actually moving through
space faster than light to accomplish it
so like in in star wars which was uh you
know we're going to jump to uh was it
light speed hyperspace i do
hyperspace
get your vocabulary hyperspace is that
is that plausible in some way like
they've worked around yeah so because
the future so you give them whatever
whatever special engines they need but
they were distinguishing the fact that
they can't just accelerate faster than
the speed of light something has to
happen
okay
in order to engage that and and the
streaking of the of the starlight that's
kind of what it might look like if you
sort of
did that so i thought that's one of the
three accurate things in the entire star
wars series that is one can talk about
that has any correspondence to physical
reality uh the other is that jar jar
binks is a very good actor
we got to take a break but when we come
back more cosmic queries on star talk
with my guest co-host paul mercurio
we're back star talk cosmic queries grab
bag edition i got my guest co-host paul
mercurio paul
uh
mercurio that feels like the planet
mercury
right was is that
is there an r in your last name there
actually is i had to change the spelling
for performing purposes uh my my
god-given name is m-e-r-c-u-r-i-o
or god gave you that name that's
interesting well yeah he and i are we're
like that and you're on a last name
basis with god
well apparently i was born and a guy in
a robe walked in and said
your name is mercurio and then they
don't know if it was god or a homeless
guy but uh i'm going with god just so i
feel important and it works every time
yeah all right so so you're born mercury
mercury and you took it out why
while i was uh
in a had a part in a show in los angeles
and my manager called me goes there's a
problem and i go what am i getting fired
from this acting job
he goes no but you will be the problem
real problem is that there's an actor in
the union with the name paul mercurio
and i just was like i went nuts i'm like
what are the statistical chances of
somebody having that same name and it
was this australian actor you may not
remember but he was in this really good
independent movie called strictly
ballroom he was a i did see i was i was
a ballroom dancer at the time i saw that
very interesting oh okay and he was a
great dancer and apparently the story
there is he was a choreographer on the
film and the actor they hired really
couldn't pull the dance moves off so
they put him in front of the camera and
he acted fine and he had a career for a
while and he did exit to eden with rosie
o'donnell and some other so he got in
the union before i did so for a while i
was paul michael mercurio my my
confirmation name was my middle name
michael you saw yourself be so pious and
i gave you the last name the
confirmation god gives you another name
hang on hang on i gotta heal a leper
hold on one second um
get some water
you had lepers in your apartment good
i'm not never visiting you
it's my door man it's the best we could
get with covin everybody else is on
unemployment
and uh and so i uh i tried three names
for a while and the end of the story is
that god forbid somebody could introduce
you and get paul michael michael
mercuria they couldn't say three names
and get it right and so i dropped the
first r in my name okay and you're
curious
but i got mercutio i got references to
shakespeare
i guess my name is sort of my i have
attended i'm an aries so i don't know if
you believe in astrology what do you
think yeah yeah a little bit and uh
that i'm sort of a mercurial kind of
human being and my wife is easy
anyway sorry that was too long an answer
all that i
all right so what do you have for the
next question uh we're out of time
thanks for tuning in everybody
both are too long explaining
exactly the absence of an r in his name
exactly in his head neil's going why did
i ask this more on this question
all right all right david goldberg two
parts hi dr tyson we get it you're a
doctor back off
uh how do astronomers know how old stars
are that's the first question you know
that's okay well there's another part to
that
yeah
i recently read that they observed a
moon forming around the planet near a
star that is only six million years old
and i was wondering how they can tell
yeah okay so that's a that question is
way deeper than most people
know
and imagine so
we look out in the universe and how long
are we alive at most 100 years
and
stars live billions of years
the universe has been around for 14
billion years
we're not sitting around so there's one
getting born and there's adolescence and
then
age and dying we don't have that luxury
all we can do is take snapshots
okay we take a snapshot over here
a snapshot over there
and we
line it all up and we scratch our heads
okay so now by
analogy let's do the same
for human beings okay so let's say we
are some insect that lives
for one day
and we want to know
how do we decide how old humans are that
we encounter
but we'll only live for one day okay so
i i amass all of my fellow insects
together
so let's take photos of humans
throughout the day bring them all back
and sit down and scratch our heads if
the insect has a head so what will they
see
they will see this a building
with
tiny
humans in it
okay
very tiny
how big is this insect this is freaking
me out no it's
okay i'm trying is it going to have to
be a mantas
it wouldn't have to be an insect just
another creature who's curious
about humans as life forms the way we
are curious about stars okay
so
that so they'll see
they'll see
women
sort of
facing this building
with distended bellies
okay
they'll see
in the building they'll see
little humans
and then they'll and they'll also see
women exiting the building
holding these little humans
okay so that's kind of interesting all
right hold on to that for a minute
they will see
wooden
boxes
going into the ground
okay
oh what's that okay oh by the way in the
same building that has the women with
distended bit uh bellies
they will see
other humans
laying down that are very wrinkled maybe
or um okay
do they see do they see my super not
fixing the leak under my skin
yes they will they will catch that and
can they kill him for that that's all i
really care about okay
so you can ask
um do
this life form are they
born in the earth in boxes
because you don't get to see the box
move these are snapshots right right and
do we do
like seeds like plants and we take them
out of the ground
and they start out wrinkly and then they
get healthier and healthier and then
they begin to shrink and then disappear
okay because you don't even know the
time vector when you're just looking out
in in the universe so you start
assembling this
and
once you bring enough of this data
together
you can start
constructing a timeline of a human being
and you might say okay um
here's another subtle point you ready
some people
have this stick in their mouth and
there's froth in their mouth
okay not many it's maybe one in a
thousand
okay
how what fraction of a day
are you brushing your teeth right it's
like a couple of minutes out of 24 hours
so most people will not be doing this
some will be so is it only this kind of
person is only ever brushing their teeth
and no one else does
or does everyone brush their teeth it's
like watching people running for
exercise these people are sort of
they're they're moving faster than most
people are moving in terms of walking
what does this mean where what does it
mean exactly or what you won't see them
moving you'll just catch them with
longer strides in a long stride with
wearing fewer clothes like you know wet
from sweat whatever that yeah right
right so all of this has to go into a
box that you sit there and scratch your
head and it's like a puzzle really and
you say well this maybe this comes
before that oh we we got this now the
distended bellies and this this place
and
the women and and do i even know that
they're women well statistically they
have longer hair
and so does because does everyone get a
distended belly
so you have to think all of this through
for me the one of the more intriguing
ones is trying to figure out whether one
kind of person
is the only one who's ever what you find
in the bathroom
or does everyone go to the bathroom you
just didn't catch it because it doesn't
take very long
okay okay because you'll just miss it
all right but you will be able to
if all this data that you're collecting
a very quick
determination can be that there's only
two types of these beings
a naked man looks one way a naked woman
looks another way well to you but if you
are a praying mantis do you even see the
difference
i mean when you see a pramence
when you see no
when you see a pigeon are you saying oh
yeah that's a female pigeon that's a
male pigeon or you look really different
no they can tell each other apart well
when i look when i look at pigeons i try
to look at them as more substantive
beings i'm not shallow like you
like hey that's pitch that picture's got
a nice body tired beings right
so what may be obvious to us would be
completely mysterious to another
creature you don't run around and judge
the gender of goldfish right you have no
clue because we don't have eyes for that
we don't no no but i'm not saying that
they that they would
say today it's gender but they'll start
to see a pattern that there's two these
these beings look one of two ways in
terms of this not size not okay but they
do but not all of them okay so
you know
uh elementary school children
okay
um unless they're completely stripped
down they're just they're just smaller
humans right
and so
so the differences grow through middle
school and high school of course but
then you still have to figure that out
that's my only point so
fortunately just for this visiting
praying mantis or whatever creature it
was there are billions of people
fortunately for astrophysicists there
are billions of stars
because if you only do something one in
a million times
and i have a billion of you out there i
will catch somebody in the act doing it
every time right all right do you need
the large numbers to see the things that
are rare
okay and then to start putting put
finding a pattern to write right data
and to create the temporal nuances of
what's happening simply from snapshots
so we look out in the universe and we
say hmm
there's a gas cloud over here
all right
and i see some stars deep within it
by the way what are stars made of
they're made of gas hmm
maybe that's a stellar
nursery
because over here i see stars
and there's no gas so where did they
come from wait could it be that these
stars dissolve themselves into a cloud
that could that that could be
it's analogous to do
are they born in these boxes and the box
doesn't come back out can i reverse or
are they born and then yeah correct so
but then so here's what you find you
ready
you keep doing this and then you find
out wait a minute this star just blew up
oh my gosh what kind of star is that
oh and you look very carefully and we
have other ways to determine it's a very
high mass star
only high mass stars blow up
and then you can look at the fragments
okay but
but wait a minute
so so it so because you could ask do
stars
are they born with very high mass and
then use up their mass over their
lifetime and then just disappear
right that's another one right that's
the i start out big and i eat up my own
flesh and i disappear but no it turns
out
stars are born at a given mass they use
some of it during their life but it's
only a very small fraction of it it
turns out and the high mass ones blow up
with hardly any difference in their mass
from when they were born and the low
mass ones never blow up and they have a
different color and
and some stars never wander far from
their birth from their nursery and you
piece all oh then you find out
then you find out there's a whole bunch
of stars here
that that
the the gas is almost entirely
dissipated
now you can't make more stars so they
must all be the same age
oh my gosh and now i have a cluster of
stars with the same birth date
well how about this other cluster over
here well the parameters are a little
different i see less gas among them but
these other things have changed
so maybe after a million years after
billionaires these things are taking
place
so this took decades
with the most powerful telescopes in the
world and one of the leading telescopes
was mount palomar in california the hale
200-inch telescope
really
put teeth in the stellar evolution
[Music]
understanding of of this universe so
it is it was a very hard task it took
many brilliant people over many decades
not only the theorists to try to figure
out what's happening inside the star
that would cause it but the observers he
was saying i see stars here but not
there
okay
how come i don't see humans in the
middle of the desert okay maybe
and how can i see more humans where
there's water
oh maybe you need water for some okay
just keep doing it right you keep doing
it just it's it's sort of this
never-ending
it's a never-ending thing and the thing
about the universe is
the bigger is your sample of stars
the greater is the chance you will see
something
that is so rare it only happens once in
a billion or trillion times
all right and so every now and then
you'll see a headline saying
astrophysicists discover a new black
hole that doesn't fit anybody's model or
understanding or well because it's the
millionth black hole we found right
so
uh you know if i if i search enough
people i'll find somebody who has every
disease you ever see
advertised on television
right
right no i'm serious
everybody's got there's something this
isn't one in a hundred thousand and one
in a million or what is it tay sachs is
it sickle cell is it uh it's my aunt
christine she's got every pain under the
sun my back my head
then she'd be a gold mine for the
investigating aliens okay she's got all
the data that's a perfect place to send
her actually let's put her on a ship all
right we're going to wrap up on this we
got to take a break oh yeah take a break
okay damn i'm taking so long to answer
no maybe a lightning round for this for
the third and uh third period absolutely
uh and we're gonna be back right after
this quick break
we're back star talk i got my guest
co-host paul mercurio paul how did
people find you on the internet uh at
paul mercurio no that was a long-hanging
fruit you could they find me repulsive
paul i'm handed paul i don't want i
don't want to be the teller of your the
jokes that are just dangling i don't i
forgot that you're so evil and uh
uh thank you
i have bad breath i have that's how i
find it yeah
they find me repulsive that's actually a
perfect way of describing me um
call me curio on on twitter is that oh
you don't care don't you you just dude i
want my people my people wanted to know
how to find it yes at paul mccurio
o one r m-e-c-u-r-i-o-1-r we talked
about this earlier i had to drop the
versus r and paul mecurio.com you know
that's one word paul mccure paul mecurio
and instagram or tiktok
instagram twitter facebook i'm thinking
about starting tick tock but i don't
know if it's tick tock is like a
commitment you got to like be ready to
get in yeah yeah and i'm not you gotta
dance and i don't know that's nobody
wants to see that yeah so you dance
you're correct nobody wants it
i didn't know you were a ballroom dancer
is there anything you haven't done like
this is amazing there's two things yeah
but no i was a
on a competitive international latin
ballroom dance team
wow yeah yeah yeah there's a team so
there were eight of us eight couples and
it was the full choreography it was it
was a yeah good friend of ours does it
and she loves it and she's in great
shape from it too it's amazing yeah that
movie came out right at that time and uh
so it was we it was a you know field
trip
for the dance group so what do you have
you gotta jump back
did i finish the second half of that
question because we found a moon
orbiting a planet orbiting a star so
what we find is the stars that are being
born in these gas clouds we also see
disks of material
and then we say to ourselves
could these disks of material
be
the proto material that will then make
planets in orbit around the star
and so sure enough this is what we
observe so
yeah and so you can observe planets
forming around stars
and then the planets themselves some of
them have discs and out of that disk
they would have their own moon so it's
pretty cool can i ask a quick follow-up
on something you said in the last
segment no unless you're a patreon
member you can all right here we go
um
okay toby sonenberg
hi neil could you please explain what
the crisis in cosmology is what are the
what are the some possible ways the
crisis can be resolved what do you think
is the most likely resolution oh this
person is doing some homework there okay
well so
old-timers it's hard to call it a crisis
it is a crisis but for old-timers it's
really hard all right i'm an old-timer i
i come from an era
an epoch okay where
we didn't know
the age or the size of the universe
because they're related to within a
factor of two
okay a factor of two
is the universe 10 billion years old or
is it 20 billion years old and if you
put all the data together people sort of
picked and chose and sifted and there
was the 10 billion year camp and the 20
billion year camp and they were warring
factions for many years but there are
two methodologies too that's right so
the methods are different the the chosen
objects cosmic
different so so this is how you get this
divide and it's on the frontier and
eventually with better telescopes better
data which is how this is always solved
all right that's the good thing about
being a scientist you can get into a
fight and in the end you both agree it's
an un
uh it's a it's an unwritten contract
that you and i have
that either you're right and i'm wrong
i'm right and you're wrong or we're both
wrong
and they'll reach a point we say we need
better data let's go have a beer
okay so that's how that works right
there's no there's no dual there's no
who shouts the loudest that's not how we
that's not how we roll
so but there's a but there's an analysis
that looks at sort of historic data and
then there's one that takes it looks at
sort of current state of things and
those or there's another one that says
here's instructions for the next wave of
observations i need you to look at it
this way because that'll help me resolve
this uncertainty
so with this factor of two
warring factions
with new data especially with the hubble
telescope and the uh
observations of the cosmic
microwave background with two satellites
three satellites that were engaged in
this one successively more precise than
the next
you we so it turned out the uncertainty
was no longer a factor of two it
narrowed and of course the the actual
answer ended up somewhere in between all
right so we're now at about 14 billion
years no one is saying 10 or 20 anymore
all right so you'd expect that if the
two warring factions the right answer is
probably somewhere in between as it
turned out to be all right so we so
we're all happy 14 billion year old
universe and then people start looking
more carefully at it they use this
method and that method and our
observations are so precise
people are saying and i forgot the two
the exact two numbers is it
14.0 and 14.6 there are two different
ages well it says the crux of the
disagreement is that 67.4 plus or minus
0.5 that's the value of the hubble
constant which then gives you the age of
the universe so so give me those two
numbers that's my 67 and the other thing
is 7.4 uh plus or minus 0.5 and 73.2
plus or minus 1.3 so these two numbers
kilometers per second per megapixel
right so those two numbers are the
fabled hubble constant and you use the
hubble constant to get the age of the
universe i was content giving this
answer in the context of the age of the
universe but now you threw in the hubble
constant in units of kilometers per
second per megaparsec because clearly
you don't want to do your job thoroughly
and i'm covering your behind
i gotta carry you go ahead
go ahead mr i know i know the universe
go ahead so
the the hubble constant version of the
age of the universe is
is the hubble constant
um
50 or is it 100
okay
that gets you these two different ages
of the universe all right uh if the
hubble constant is 50 then the age of
the universe
is 20 billion years if the hubble
constant is 100 then the age of the
universe is 10 billion years so but
point is if you want to speak in hubble
if you want to be hubble constant fluent
that's fine those two numbers which used
to have a huge uncertainty no
no longer has a huge uncertainty but now
they each have their own camps because
the uncertainty in each number excludes
the other number
okay so we measure those two numbers so
precisely
that the 73 doesn't allow the 67 in its
error bars
in the on range of uncertainty you know
the uncertainty when you
read uh election polls
leading by sixty percent plus or minus
three percent okay that's an uncertainty
where the data can't distinguish so if
you put the uncertainties around those
two numbers the uncertainties don't
overlap
so that's a crisis in cosmology well
what is what camps are you in and and
i'm just saying
to call that a crisis what a luxury of
precision measurement right you would
prefer the crisis because you you as a
as a scientist like the challenge of
trying to figure things out and come to
resolution and this is a challenge still
for you and when you have a crisis
uh it energizes people that's correct we
call it a crisis because the two had
those two numbers had uncertainties that
overlapped then it's just a matter of
time you get some better data it might
be
that these two methods because it uses
different methods
too can you just hit on that for a
second i mean maybe everybody listening
knows but like
and which method do you subscribe to
because i don't i don't i i i don't
i have no such investment in my
emotional energy i step back and i
embrace it all it is
wow this guy just got really esoteric
and
can i have some of what you're smoking
in the break because that was a pretty
awesome answer man no it'd be something
like you want to measure the the length
of uh
i don't know uh the length of some
object
and one person pulls out their pocket
ruler and they do it another person
pulls out a laser and another person
pulls out
like an inch worm okay
and then they get three different
results right but every time they repeat
it they get approximately the same
results and the results don't agree with
each other right so you have to say to
yourself
one of these results is wrong
or maybe
the inchworm
is relativistically affected i don't
know
you have to you know i mean it could
force another understanding of the world
third measurement i mean i i mean they
both i mean they both seem valid i mean
one is when the universe began and then
using theories to predict today exactly
they're completely valid and that's why
we're scratching our heads or
they they are irreconcilable
and there's new physics that we need to
put on the table that tells us why
that's we all love new physics because
it open it's like you you broke through
a door and on the other side of the door
is this beam of knowledge and wisdom
that could shed light on other stuff
that had you that still keeps as you
scratch in your head
and and let me give an obscure example
of this we have what are called gps
satellites you heard them
and they orbit they're in a place in
earth's gravity field where their clocks
tick faster than our clocks
okay all according to relativity
if einstein's relativity had not yet
been discovered
and we launched these satellites for the
sole purpose of establishing a
coordinate grid on earth where timing is
essential
we would see that it would constantly be
sending us time that's too fast
and we'd say engineers what did you
design you must have made a mistake go
back to the circuit board go fix it
check your drawings we would first
assume that there was some mechanical
problem with it and the engineers say no
here's the here's the twin of it on
earth and it's cats and no
so well what's going on
we can't we can't figure it out and so
that would be a dilemma and then
einstein would come along and say we
have the general theory of relativity
that's explained trivially bada bing a
whole new field of physics opens up so
most crises in science
lead i hate the word crises because that
yeah it implies human yeah exactly um
dilemma how about dilemma how about that
most dilemmas
lead to
uh
physics you break breakthroughs that's
there you go so that's the whole story
there yeah well i knew that i just
didn't want to say anything um
lightning round yeah we're gonna do
lightning round okay we got some really
great questions that we want to get to
taking too long to answer these no
you're not it's always interesting i
fall asleep in the middle but then i
wake up
um
all right peter peter jacobs
while i'm facing the chalkboard that's
when you catch up on your nose yeah
you're reading i'm on your feet shooting
spit balls at your back of your neck um
peter jacobs uh we're gonna do he's got
two questions let's do the first one if
two black holes collide
uh can we tell their relative uh
relations with uh ligo
and how do they affect the final
rotation of the resultant black hole
excellent so this is lightning round so
ligo the laser interferometer
gravitational wave observatory
is exquisitely tuned to look at the
ripples through the fabric of space and
time
pred predicted by einstein in his
general theory of relativity that when
you have a disturbance a gravitational
disturbance in the space-time continuum
it sends a ripple moving at the speed of
light and two colliding black black
holes will do that before they built
ligo they set up models of what all
manner of black hole collisions would
look like equal mass very different mass
uh slightly different mass what was the
basis for the models is this is
i'm not making a joke is this analogous
to sort of this praying mantis taking a
snapshot of of us on earth and putting
it because we're not going to have a
million examples here so you want to set
up a catalog
that because you know general relativity
it works we know black holes we think we
know what will happen when they collide
and so we say okay here is the
gravitational wave signature
that we just measured let's hold that up
to our catalog and which one does it
come closest to there it is a 30 solar
mass black hole and a 4 and a 15 solar
mass black hole there you have it now
depending on how far away they were when
they started their spiral they have
what's called angular momentum
and this is the momentum of rotation
and that
some of that angular momentum is carried
away
uh but uh
i i don't know if it's most but much of
it remains within the system and you
have a rotating black hole so black
holes rotate too just like everybody
else
okay we're going to get to the next one
thomas you no no he had a second
question you said he did oh okay i was
just trying to get to everybody so i
figured let's do it okay uh why bother
sending a probe to another star when it
will most likely find one we sent later
um
isn't that statistically unlikely though
i think he meant the opposite of that i
think he might what he might be saying
is
if you send a probe to another and i
don't want to invent a question that
he's not thinking but
here's a version of that that i he might
mean you send a probe to another star
it'll take 50 years or even even
you know okay
but in those 50 years we invent a way
to
tunnel or wormhole to the star
and so you so you get there faster than
that
would have ever arrived because when we
sent it we didn't have that technology
yet
but it developed so there it is just
passing it by saying hello
right right right so people have argued
why don't we wait until the technology
is better
uh and then do it right
to send the probe to
right but correct but it's not like
we're doing it wrong
is that i mean that sort of presupposes
that we're getting information that's
inaccurate or no no no it's just it says
why bother right if if you're gonna say
if you're in california and you say we
discovered gold put the notice on the
back of a tortoise okay and send it back
east
you can say no let's wait until the
railroad is built or we'll have to wait
until
right now
let's make it a little past the turtle
in st louis you know we'll get it will
be better
so
i think that might be what he means but
okay okay keep going thomas hugh uh
hello team has anyone tried to uh
calculate the cost and natural resources
of planet earth if spacex would follow
through with the plans to colonize mars
so that that implies that the
colonization of mars requires taking
natural resources from earth to put it
there
but if you're going to colonize the way
to do it is do you do everything in situ
okay you want it this is the buzzword in
situ resource utilization isru google it
okay and nasa has full running pages and
when you get to a destination dig in the
soils get the carbon dioxide split it
get the water split the water molecule
you get oxygen you can breathe it the
hydrogen you get a rocket fuel all of
this is what martian the movie two hours
thank you hello
do we need anything else to be matt
damon the most brilliant second most
brilliant next to neil degrasse tyson
man in the world anyway go ahead
so ideally that's what you would do
otherwise no i don't whatever they have
to take to have lunch for a year that's
not going to throw earth off its axis a
lot of subway sandwiches that kind of
thing um
real quick we have to wrap up i mean
what are some of the advantages of
colonizing
uh mars
well if an asteroid takes out earth then
humans don't go completely extinct
but that's a very negative attitude
no i don't i don't i i'm a contrarian
there i don't
see i i don't even agree that that's why
you should do it so we have more eggs in
more than one basket if you have the
technology to
go to mars terraform it colonize it with
a billion people it seems to me you have
the technology to deflect that asteroid
that's headed for earth okay oh we're
destroying earth with global warming and
the billionaires are all escaping and
they're going to form another planet and
then they're going to terraform that
planet because elon is into terraforming
it seems to me if we have the power
to terraform and you redirect the folk
into earth then we have the power to
turn earth back into earth yeah okay so
yeah don't worry we're cool here all
right one last question let's slip it
out want to slip one more in okay this
is um
alexander wiznet if gravity is due to
mass and acceleration could we get an
object with enough gravity to pull
something at the speed of light
if you fall into a black hole
basically
you come near the speed of light as you
become the end and what happens is as
you come near the speed of light
uh
things we it's it's harder to
distinguish you as a blob of mass from
you of what would then become a blob of
energy so the mass energy equation very
much favors
the
the conversion of matter into energy and
so
um so yes is the answer and that happens
in black holes all the time and if you
want to if you don't believe me try it
call me up
tell me
hey neil i'm falling through a black oh
just like you said just like you said i
think you're breaking up a little oh my
god i'm breaking up can you hear me now
wait let me go to
another this was not a good idea
and then neil makes some notes and moves
on with no emotionality about it
uh we are done
dude thanks thanks for coming in for
this this is so fun and it's good to see
you hadn't seen in a couple of years
nice to know you're still out there
and yes and
holding down the cold bear for it
absolutely
are you going to be back on sue we got
to get you let's colbert i got it i i
got to write another book to get back on
i got to earn it you know all right
that's what that is let me put a word in
for you
you know this up and coming scientists
you might have heard him uh
yeah he's got a thing or two uh thanks
for this is always great it's awesome
you know what i said i was on his show
march 2020.
like march 9th
all right it was like the last week that
he you're the reason covered shut
everything down
and he says what do you think of this
covert thing and i all i said was
it is
an experiment
in whether
humans will heed the advice
of science and medical professionals
right and that's what i said okay that's
all i said and we're continuing this is
an experiment
that's a show or not a day show for
another day but yeah that's a really
great answer and you hit it on the head
what it is this is uh
we out thanks paul this has been star
talk cosmic queries edition and i've
been your host
neil degrasse tyson as always bidding
you
to keep looking up
[Music]